on a rainy night Mike enslin gets out of
his car and rushes to a motel all sucked
he seems to be in a hurry Mike is the
author of cheesy horror tour guide books
he travels from City to City staying at
supposedly haunted places and then
writes a summary of them for his book in
this instance he meets the motel owner
and inquires about the most haunted room
initially the latter hesitates but then
he assigns him a key to room 14. Mike
takes it and immediately checks into his
room by the looks on his face it is
evident that he doesn't believe in the
Supernatural for the first few minutes
Mike uses his equipment to detect
anything unusual in the room however
when he doesn't find anything he gets
bored and falls asleep the next morning
he wakes up early and leaves he then
goes to a bookstore for his book signing
event a few people are in attendance and
Mike talks about paranormal activities
he presents his view of not believing in
ghostly activities and all the stuff
being just fantasy he should probably
get someone else to do his marketing as
he signs the books for his readers a
young girl comes to him with a very old
book of his it is revealed that Mike
used to write emotional stories before
he became a paranormal writer the girl
tells him that she was genuinely touched
by the book because it seemed too
authentic especially the part about the
relationship between father and daughter
she then asks if that really happened
Mike says no but his expression suggests
otherwise after the book event Mike
heads back to his home in Los Angeles he
immediately goes to the beach to enjoy
surfing as he is riding the waves a
helicopter passes above him with a
banner Mike tries to read it but just
then he is Swept Away by a massive wave
Mike chokes on the seawater but somehow
manages to survive after he gets up he
goes to a post office and picks up his
mail as he goes through it a postcard
catches his eye it is a certain dolphin
hotel's card which says don't enter 1408
on the back Mike is instantly intrigued
by this so he calls the said hotel for
information about room 1408 however the
receptionist mentions that the room is
unavailable for any date He suggests
that Mike book other rooms but our
protagonist is not one who gives up
easily and sense he starts looking up
room 1408 of Dolphin Hotel on the
internet shockingly Mike learns that
some people committed the unthinkable in
that room so it has been closed for
years in the next scene Mike causes
publisher Sam to ask about the hotel and
the latter mentions that there is a law
that allows him to file a lawsuit if
they don't give him the room that is
vacant next Mike arrives in New York and
takes a cab to the Dolphin Hotel he
inspects the place meticulously but
notices nothing creepy about it after a
while a woman at the reception enters
his details when Mike says that he wants
to book room 1408 the woman gets shocked
and immediately sends him to the manager
Gerald's office at his office Gerald
asks Mike how long he wants to stay in
that room the latter replies he wants to
stay overnight but Gerald reveals that
no one has lasted there for more than an
hour he also brings up the fact that 56
people have died in that room so far
after this Gerald gives Mike his diary
with all the information about the
deaths saying he cannot stay in that
room however our stubborn protagonist is
not well willing to give up on the room
so easily he sees it as the perfect
opportunity to make good content for his
new book Mike keeps insisting that he
won't leave until he gets what he wants
and in the end Gerald hesitantly hands
him the key to room 1408 the two then
take an elevator to the 14th floor soon
the elevator dings and they part ways
Mike walks through the hallway reading
the diary given by Gerald at first
everything seems normal as he sees a
maid passing by however something seems
eerily unsettling Mike continues to 1408
and unlocks the room he turns on the
lights and shuts the door he then takes
out a tape recorder and starts recording
his voice as he walks around the room
Mike describes the place in detail
saying it is much more boring than he
had expected but right then he is
startled by a song that begins playing
on the radio when Mike turns around he
sees two chocolates placed on his pillow
and he eats one of them he hears some
noises and suspects that somebody is in
the room after turning off the music
Mike gets excited thinking he has
finally found something to write about
but he still doesn't realize that
something is off with the place Mike
believes that the hotel staff are simply
trying to scare him away soon the room
starts heating automatically he tries
lowering the thermostat down but it
keeps getting hotter when the condition
becomes unbearable Mike calls the hotel
operator asking for a mechanic to fix
the issue after he hangs up he checks
the room with UV lights and eerily finds
blood stains everywhere soon a mechanic
knocks on the door and Mike excitedly
greets him however the man refuses to
enter the room saying he fears for his
life instead he guides Mike on how to
repair the thermostat himself the latter
follows the instructions and manages to
bring the temperature down but when he
turns around to thank the mechanic there
is no one there all of a sudden the
radio turns on again and a song starts
playing loudly the clock on the radio
automatically sets for a timer of 60
Minutes a high-pitched tingling sound
also starts playing and Mike loses his
hearing for a while he frantically looks
out of the window and although there is
a lot of traffic he can't hear anything
other than the tingling voice just then
the window closes on its own crushing
his hand Mike screams in pain as he goes
to the bathroom to clean his wound but
the faucet's water changes to Boiling
immediately and burns his hands back in
the room Mike is putting a bandage on
his hand when the song We've Only Just
Begun starts playing enraged he
disconnects the radio from the outlet
but the timer is still running at this
point Mike finally realizes that he is
in trouble so he gathers all this stuff
and tries getting out of the room but to
his bad luck the key breaks in half the
doorknob also falls off scared Mike
tries kicking the door open but to no
avail he then rushes to the window
crying for help and spots a man in the
adjacent building Mike screams to grab
his attention but soon realizes that it
is his own reflection just then a creepy
figure approaches his mirrored self with
a knife and kills him when Mike turns
around he sees the same entity behind
him too when I saw this movie in
theaters this part made me pee a little
he drops to the floor and closes his
eyes waiting for his demise but when he
regains his senses The Entity is nowhere
to be seen this worries Mike and now he
is convinced that he is hallucinating as
he searches for answers he suddenly
remembers that the hotel manager had
given him booze before coming to the
room he suspects that it was drugged and
that's why he's been seeing things he
also thinks that the chocolate he ate
earlier was laced with something
suddenly the TV in the room starts
showing a video of Mike and his family
he is playing with his ex-wife Lily and
their daughter Katie Mike gets emotional
as he walks towards the TV he tries to
feel his daughter's face on the screen
but the TV abruptly shuts down Mike then
starts hearing a baby cry next door he
assumes there must be a woman with the
baby and he bangs the wall requesting
for help unfortunately this only
aggravates the situation as the voice of
the baby crying gets louder deafening
Mike in a state of panic he throws its
share at the wall finally making the
sound go away but then something creepy
happens Mike notices blood dripping from
the cracked wall almost as if he hit an
actual person in the next scene Mike
inspects the floor plan and learns that
there are several room rooms next to his
what in a hotel you're kidding me since
the door is jammed he decides to climb
out the window and call for help Mike
slowly steps out and walks onto the
ledge of the building however as he
reaches a bit further he hauntingly
learns that the hotel doesn't contain
any other rooms except 1408. oh you're
kidding me panicked he changes Direction
and starts heading back to his room but
on the way a ghastly woman appears next
to him causing him to nearly fall Mike
somehow holds on and he notices the
woman committing the unthinkable from
the ledge he then climbs back inside
after which the window shuts closed
automatically when Mike inspects the
floor plan again he learns that it has
now changed completely only his room is
shown with the rest of the hotel blacked
out to add to the mystery Mike notices
that room 1408 has changed in appearance
the door and windows are now completely
blocked by concrete walls Mike cannot
believe that this is happening to him so
he listens to his earlier recording to
check his sanity to his horror the
recording also says that the room is
haunted confused to not knowing what to
do Mike looks through his bag and finds
a laptop he connects to a wireless
network and calls Lily through a video
chat he nervously tells her that he is
trapped in a weird place and asks her to
call the cops to Dolphin Hotel room 1408
but as he is giving her more information
the sprinkler suddenly activate and
spray water all over the room this
unfortunately destroys the laptop as
well as all the other electronics in the
room after Mike turns off the sprinklers
the room starts freezing and it gets
extremely cold there he tries burning
different stuff in the room to keep
himself warm sometime later as Mike is
on the verge of death he gets a call on
his laptop which is miraculously
repaired itself Lily is on the other end
and she mentions that the cops are at
the hotel room 1408 however she reveals
that the room is empty just then the
laptop glitches and a supernatural mic
begins speaking to his ex-wife through
the call he asks Lily to come to room
1408 presumably to trap her the real
Mike tries his best to stop his ex-wife
from coming but his voice cannot be
heard suddenly everything starts to
rumble all items in the room break the
wall cracks and there's debris all
around it starts raining Mike hits a
painting of a ship and water begins
pouring inside the room Mike is now
drowning fighting for his life but after
a bit of struggling he sees A Light
Above him and swims toward it as he
reaches the surface he shockingly finds
himself on the beach from earlier a
helicopter soon passes by and this time
he is able to read the banner it says to
get great life insurance call XXX 1408
when Mike wakes up sometime later he
finds himself in a hospital in La his
ex-wife Lily is by his side trying to
comfort him Mike wastes no time and
explains about the incidence of Dolphin
Hotel 1408 however Lily says that she
hasn't heard of that hotel some days
later Mike starts living a normal life
with Lily they have decided to give
their relationship one more try one
night during dinner Mike seems composed
body suddenly sees a waitress he looks
exactly like the ghost from room 1408
Mike is startled but when he looks at
her again he realizes he was just
hallucinating to keep himself distracted
Mike starts writing about his experience
of room 1408 soon he completes his
manuscript and decides to print it later
he goes to the post office to mail it to
his publisher in New York the man at the
counter turns towards him saying they
are closed for today Mike becomes
shocked when he sees his face he
remembers him as the same bell boy at
the Dolphin Hotel who offered to take
his bags suddenly all the people in the
post office start destroying the room
and Mike finds himself in 1408 once
again this is when he realizes that the
past week was simply a dream as he is
still trapped to make matters worse the
room is now in complete ruins as Mike
shouts for help his daughter arrives in
the room she calls him daddy and asks
for help Mike knows that he is
hallucinating again but he cannot resist
himself from hugging her here it is
revealed that Katie died some years ago
due to cancer and this is the reason
Mike and Lily drifted apart back in the
room he tells Katie that they will live
together as a family and no one will
take her away but right then the little
girl dies in his arms Mike cries saying
can't take her twice all of a sudden
loud music plays on the radio and
Katie's body shatters into concrete
debris Mike goes crazy and starts
breaking and throwing stuff as the music
keeps on playing we noticed that the
timer on the radio is about to end in
the next scene the clock hits zero and
he finds himself in the original room
1408 it is fully furnished and nothing
appears to be broken the clock is also
reset to another one hour timer
indicating that Mike has been trapped in
an endless loop suddenly the telephone
ranks and Mike immediately picks it up
he asks why didn't you kill me to which
the operator replies that he can choose
to relive that hour again and again or
end his life at the same time Mike
notices the grave of himself and his
daughter Katie he realizes that the room
is forcing him to commit the unthinkable
just like all the previous occupants
meanwhile the operator on the phone asks
if he is ready to check out or not Mike
hesitates for a while and then says no
in response the operator mentions that
his wife will be there soon and hangs up
hearing this Mike panic decides to end
it all he sees a bottle of bourbon given
by the manager which is now full acting
quickly he makes a Molotov out of it
lights it on fire and then throws it
against the wall before long the fire
alarm goes off and everyone in the hotel
panics Lily who has just arrived at the
hotel tells the police that Mike is
inside room 1408 on the 14th floor
meanwhile Mike sits calmly in his room
smoking a cigarette as the place burns
down in flames he laughs maniacally
content that the room is finally going
to be destroyed the scene then cuts to
Mike's funeral revealing that he did not
survive Lily gives a heartfelt speech
saying Katie and Mike are finally
together now after the ceremony ends
Gerald the manager at Dolphin Hotel
approaches Lily with Mike's belongings
in a box however she refuses to take
them saying she wants to move on now
after a while his Gerald is back in his
car he finds a tape recorder amongst
Mike's belongings when he plays it he
hears The Haunting final moments of Mike
along with the screams of Katie suddenly
Gerald sees the little girl in the
mirror and he turns back he notices a
completely burnt mic terrified Gerald
places the tape recorder back in the box
and drives off in the final scene we see
the spirit of Mike still trapped in room
1408 as he wanders around he hears Katie
calling him daddy from nearby subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching